y
[Música]
termino la guerra en afganistán faltando
un minuto para la medianoche el último
soldado estadounidense a bordo un avión
de evacuación en una imagen simbólica
que concluyó 20 años desde la invasión
estadounidense
líderes talibanes asisten a esta hora a
una asamblea para celebrar la retirada
ahora la unión europea' teme una nueva
ola migratoria consecuencia de la toma
de control del talibán en afganistán y
el consejo de seguridad de naciones
unidas adoptó una resolución advirtiendo
a los extremistas contra el
incumplimiento de sus compromisos con
los derechos humanos en el país asiático
una zona protegida en kabul quedó
descartada
y en eeuu el fenómeno a ida se degradó a
tormenta tropical pero su avance
mantiene una alta peligrosidad de tras
causar daños catastróficos como huracán
en luisiana y misisipí ya se cuentan al
menos dos fallecidos además de los
enormes daños a la infraestructura y
siguen las tareas de búsqueda y rescate
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante en france
24 terminaron 20 años de guerra en
afganistán patrocinada principalmente
por eeuu se cobró la vida de casi 2.500
soldados estadounidenses y unos 240 mil
afganos y costó unos 2 billones de
dólares el último avión salió del
aeropuerto de kabul un minuto antes de
la medianoche se difundió la imagen
simbólica del mayor general cruiser
donaghue el último soldado abordando el
vuelo de evacuación estadounidense que
cerró dos décadas de enfrentamientos y
que se dio en su totalidad del poder al
tal iván antes del amanecer los
extremistas tomaron control del
aeropuerto en un último paso después de
la toma de kabul el pasado 15 de agosto
y dispararon al aire para celebrar la
que llamaron la liberación de afganistán
hasta ahora los líderes extremistas
asisten a una asamblea en kabul para
conmemorar la retirada de eeuu en
washington nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez nos habló de las
reacciones del presidente joe biden que
defendió hasta el final la salida
si defendió hasta el final y luego va a
seguir defendiendo a pesar de que osama
bin laden pues fue asesinado no en
afganistán sino en pakistán en el 2011 y
a pesar de haber dado estos golpes
bélicos precisos no en afganistán sino
en pakistán eeuu siguió en afganistán de
10 años más entrenando educando y
armando a miles de personas y analistas
lo que están diciendo en eeuu es que
precisamente la presencia de eeuu
continua después de haber cumplido su
objetivo de acabar con osama bin laden
le dio este resurgimiento ese impulso
para que los talibanes pues empezarán a
crecer
revivieran y hoy pues se tomen el
control total de afganistán con el
retiro estadounidense del consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas adoptó una
resolución mediante la cual espera que
el talibanes respete sus compromisos con
los derechos humanos en afganistán
el documento no establece una zona
protegida en kabul y es visto más como
una advertencia diplomática al grupo
extremista yanira gómez muñoz nos
explica
más que una resolución el texto 2.593
aprobado por el consejo de seguridad de
la onu interpela al honor de los
talibanes aunque les instan a cumplir
sus compromisos en afganistán sus puntos
son una petición constante al grupo el
consejo espera que el talibán haga
efectiva las salidas de los afganos y
extranjeros que quieran marcharse de
forma segura y ordenada así como una
entrada a la ayuda de naciones unidas
pero además les solicita respetar los
derechos humanos de mujeres niños y
minorías intentar llegar a una solución
política que incluye a las afganas no
usar el país para amenazar a atacar o
acoger a terroristas y finalmente le
pide cumplir con esta y otras promesas
futuras which are lift no podemos llevar
por aire a todo un país hasta un lugar
seguro este es el momento en el que la
diplomacia debe intensificarse al
aprobar esta resolución el consejo de
seguridad ha demostrado que el mundo
espera que el talibán cumple estas
promesas hoy mañana y después del 31 de
agosto western force 13 de 15 países
miembros estuvieron de acuerdo en el
tono tildado por analistas de ligero y
de mensaje político
francia que buscaba establecer una zona
segura en kabul para presionar y
proteger el aeropuerto no logró una
referencia
mientras que china y rusia se
abstuvieron alegando desorden de
accidente fuga de cerebros y efectos
económicos nocivos para el país a pesar
de que la resolución fue propuesta con
el telón de fondo de un terrible ataque
terrorista los autores se negaron
categóricamente a referirse a un pasaje
de la lucha contra el terrorismo que
contiene organizaciones terroristas
reconocidas internacionalmente
si bien la resolución busca transmitir
unión internacional la pelota está en
tejado talibán que ya declaró la total
independencia de afganistán
y los ministros de interior de la unión
europea se reúnen a esta hora en
bruselas para abordar la gestión de una
posible ola migratoria proveniente de
afganistán y de tras la toma de los
talibanes
los países europeos temen una nueva
crisis como la ocurrida en 2015 por la
guerra en siria detalles con nuestra
corresponsal en bruselas esther herrera
con la toma de los talibanes en
afganistán las miles de personas
evacuadas y las personas que aún quedan
en su territorio los países europeos se
centran ahora en cómo evitar una posible
crisis migratoria como la ocurrida en
2015 los países europeos están
profundamente divididos desde hace años
sobre cómo gestionar la migración de
hecho existe una propuesta que está
bloqueada desde hace un año por ello los
ministros de interior reunidos hoy en
bruselas se van a centrar sobre todo en
cómo gestionar esta crisis pero sin
hablar sobre los números sin decir
exactamente cuántos refugiados están
dispuestos a acoger sino que sobre todo
se centrarán en cómo ayudar a los países
de la región pakistán irán o
kirguizistán en esta posible acogida de
refugiados teniendo en cuenta que ya
acoge a un gran número de asilados de
este país de hecho por otra parte están
los más de 2.000 personas evacuadas a la
unión europea a través de españa y que
aún los 27 tienen que decidir cómo van a
ser repartidos entre los 26 es algo que
prefieren dejar más bien en manos de los
cancilleres europeos que se reunirán a
finales de esta semana aún así el debate
se antoja especialmente complicado
porque como todo tiene un revés político
alemania celebra elecciones el mes que
viene y francia la próxima primavera con
la vista puesta en cómo reaccionar a la
extrema derecha anti inmigración sobre
esta cuestión
y vamos al análisis con el doctor juan
bélico director del programa de
delincuencia organizada transnacional en
el centro de estudios de seguridad
hemisféricos universidad de buenos aires
y profesor de la escuela de gobierno
andén university de panamá gracias y dos
décadas de guerra finalizaron de una
forma vergonzosa para eeuu y la otan el
talibán de nuevo en el poder cuál es su
balance
bueno estamos en una situación muy
complicada y efectivamente como usted
dice el talibán está nuevamente en el
poder y esto no es una situación que
agrade a nadie y la verdad es que se
ingresó a esa guerra para quitar los
nexos entre el talibán y al-qaeda y eso
efectivamente logró romperse hasta
cierto punto pero la situación hoy es
sumamente compleja los talibanes han
regresado y han regresado de la mano de
estados unidos que finalmente admiten no
poder controlar la situación en el
territorio esta es la realidad y los
talibanes se supone que se van a
comportar de manera distinta de lo que
lo han hecho en hasta hace dos décadas
anteriores los primeros indicios que
tenemos son contradictorios porque si
bien los mensajes que dicen o que emiten
intentan transmitir tranquilidad la
realidad es que en la práctica tenemos
una situación muy distinta y no sabemos
muy bien del temor que tiene la
población que está huyendo y algunas
versiones no confirmadas aunque algunas
si le permiten darle credibilidad
no han cambiado su actitud y son
terriblemente discriminatorios en
relación a la mujer de hecho dicen que
las mujeres no van a tener problemas con
las mujeres sin embargo al mismo tiempo
están recomendando a las mujeres no
salir a la calle porque ellos no pueden
asegurar que todos los talibanes sepan
cómo manejarse frente a las mujeres y
esto claramente es un problema
precisamente por ahí quería preguntarle
la población civil especialmente niños y
mujeres están en riesgo sus derechos
humanos y sus vidas amenazadas por la
imposición de un islam que se prevé
radical pese a los discursos que ustedes
bien dice se han mostrado moderados que
le espera al pueblo afgano
bueno no sabemos que le espera el pueblo
afgano no aparentemente nada bueno la
realidad es que las escenas que vemos en
la calle con hombres talibanes armados
hasta los dientes azotando a las mujeres
y a cualquiera que no se comporte de
manera adecuada no es una buena señal y
las mujeres están huyendo del país una
de las principales anclas principales
periodistas de los de la televisora
afgana ha abandonado el país en el día
de ayer a pesar de que se les dieron
supuestas garantías de que iba a poder
trabajar sin embargo ha sido desplazada
de su noticiero
y eso indica que hay que definitivamente
va a haber problemas con este tema
hay una crisis migratoria en ciernes
esto está claro recordemos que
afganistán es un país multiétnico en la
nación no respeta no coincide con el
estado es un estado multiétnico y hay
una etnia predominante que es la pastún
que está digamos dividida entre pakistán
y afganistán y eso pone en el escenario
también a pakistán que por cierto
también teme que el talibán dentro de su
propio territorio se convierta en un
problema por un lado y por otro lado hay
una facción del issys que está operando
que aparte es parte de la interna
digamos pastor que está en el poder
actualmente
mayoritariamente los talibanes son
pastores no todos pero ahora una buena
mayoría
pero tiene un vídeo que este conflicto
se adapta cristal por otra parte tenemos
sin servicios pero lo tengo que
interrumpir se nos va el tiempo gracias
por su análisis y en un cambio de tema
rápidamente a ida se degradó a tormenta
tropical a pesar de esto ya causó daños
catastróficos veamos
el huracán aida se degrada a medida que
continúa su impulso hacia el noreste
pero los residentes de luisiana están
haciendo un balance del daño dejado a su
paso
por las cosas simplemente empezaron a
desmoronarse a volar se tengo un lugar
seco en mi casa mi techo se cayó perdí
toda mi ropa mis muebles mis utensilios
todo ahorita mismo no tengo nada
los escombros árboles caídos y líneas
eléctricas llenaron las calles de nueva
orleans pero la ciudad se ha librado de
las inundaciones generalizadas que se
vieron después del huracán katrina en
si hay luz al final del túnel hoy es
difícil verlo es nuestro sistema de
diques el que ha funcionado
extremadamente bien ha habido una
evaluación preliminar de daños de diques
no creemos que haya un solo dique en
ninguna parte ahora que realmente se
haya quebrado que haya fracasado
aunque los diques aguantaron un par se
desbordaron las marejadas ciclónicas y
las fuertes lluvias han provocado
inundaciones en varias áreas incluidas
la place los esfuerzos de rescate están
en camino vía marítima y aérea los
vientos de más de 200 kilómetros por
hora derribaron cables eléctricos en
todo el estado lo que provocó que más de
un millón de hogares y negocios estén
sin electricidad los daños han sido tan
extensos que las autoridades dicen que
podría tardar semanas en hacer las
reparaciones los hospitales de luisiana
ya estaban rebosando de pacientes de
kobe 19 antes de la llegada de ied a la
pérdida de electricidad solo agrega aún
más presión a un sistema de salud bajo
tensión
y 17 días después del terremoto de haití
la población se enfrenta a una severa
inseguridad alimentaria a malbéne urbana
con los detalles
estos sobrevivientes de complejo al sur
de haití hacen fila para recibir su
pequeña ración de alimentos repartidas
con dificultad por las organizaciones
humanitarias que buscan atender los
afectados por el terremoto
mientras que en la localidad de nan
consell en las montañas del sur del país
no lejos del epicentro del sismo los
hombres se reúnen para vender lo que
quedó de su ganado buscan obtener algo
de dinero para alimentar a sus hijos o
pagar los funerales de los miembros
fallecidos de su familia
mi casa fue destruida por el terremoto
varios miembros de mi familia murieron
tenía 13 cabras 11 murieron me quedan
dos más ya vine al mercado para ver si
puedo vender las dos que quedan no
tenemos nada necesitamos ayuda a haití
el país más pobre de américa es además
uno con los niveles más altos de
inseguridad alimentaria en el mundo el
terremoto de magnitud 7.2 del 14 de
agosto agravó aún más la situación
devastando cultivos contaminando fuentes
de agua potable y destruyendo días que
dejaron aislados a miles de damnificados
según el programa mundial de alimentos
más de 215 mil personas necesitan una
asistencia alimentaria urgente sobre
todo en los tres departamentos más
afectados su grand anse y nippes hasta
los años 80 haití fue autosuficiente
pero la isla comenzó a flexibilizar las
restricciones a la importación de
productos básicos y bajo los aranceles
importando los excedentes de cultivos
estadounidenses una decisión que terminó
por destruir su economía arrocera además
el cambio climático ha golpeado la isla
que es vulnerable a sequías y huracanes
cada vez más extremos
hasta aquí el informativo siga con
nosotros
[Música]